Netflix just released specials for three
of the most famous comedians on Earth
Dave Chappelle Ricky Jas and Pete
Davidson are arguably some of the most
recognizable names and standup but when
it comes to their actual comedy the
styles could not be more different men
test boundaries and no man tests more
boundaries than a trans man the dreamer
Armageddon and turbo Fonzerelli all came
out within a few weeks of each other and
combined for over 22.5 million total
views but what might be even more
impressive is that Dave Chappelle
generated 12.4 million of those views
all by himself followed by Ricky dvas
with 8 million of the pot and Pete
Davidson contributing 2.3